We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P, here's
a caller who apparently believes that me interviewing
them is so important that I may end up judged
by God on Judgment Day negatively if I don't
interview them.
Take a listen to this.
Yeah.
You will be held accountable for every soul
that has missed the word of God because you
didn't have me on your show.
Do you understand that you will be held accountable
on Judgment Day?
Yeah, very scary.
Very, very scary threat.
And, um, uh, I guess that's something we should
look into because, uh, the apocalypse can
be pretty bad.
I've heard about people being raptured and
it's both painful and embarrassing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Uh, there has been a helicopter in New York
City and this actually relates to something
I've been thinking of for a long time, which
is just more generally the, the risk that,
uh, aviation over the New York skyline represented
when I lived in New York.
I thought about this a lot, including with
the uh, landing pattern of for Laguardia Airport.
We'll talk about that on the bonus show and
get into detail about it.
Uh, also the governor of Alabama has signed
into law, a chemical castration bill, which
I want to discuss with you.
Uh, and California will become the first state
to extend health benefits to some people,
some people who are in the United States illegally.
Three really important stories plus some more
behind the scenes stuff that's going on on
the show and lots of other interesting things
get the bonus show.
There's two ways to do it.
At least two that I can think of off hand.
Become a member@wwwdotjoinpacman.com coupon
code.
This is 2020 saves you 40%.
You still get all the benefits, including
the world famous daily bonus show on which
we regularly hear from producer Pat, uh, become
a patron at the $5 a month or greater level.
patrion.com/david Pakman show another way
to get instant access to the David Pakman
show bonus show.
Uh, and we will speak to you then and otherwise,
you'll have to wait until tomorrow where there
will be a really great show, including the
return of Patriot male and much, much more.
That's it for today,